[Music]
it's 427 bce
and the worst internal conflict ever to
occur in the ancient greek world
is in its fourth year the peloponnesian
war
is being fought between the city-states
of athens and sparta
as well as their allies the athenians
can't match the formidable spartan
army on land so they've abandoned the
countryside
and moved inside the walls surrounding
their city and port
now provisioned by a superior fleet and
extensive
maritime empire the cramped conditions
have taken a toll
and a recent plague wiped out a third of
the population
but city life goes on archaeas and
dexalea
live in the center of athens as a
painter of high-class pottery
our kiosk is relatively well off and
takes great
interest in the city's affairs dexalea
on the other hand
can't participate in politics or own
property
the couple are grateful to the gods that
three of their four children
a son and two daughters have survived
past infancy
many parents see daughters as a
liability since they require
dowries to find husbands but archaeas is
confident that his wealth will allow him
to make good matches for them
without going bankrupt like many
athenians
the family owns slaves originally from
thrassi
they were captured in war thrata does
most of the housework and helps raise
the children
phylon is a pedogogos who supervises the
son's education
teaching him reading and writing our
kiosk is up early because there's a
meeting of the ecclesia
the assembly of citizens taking place at
dawn
before setting out he burns incense and
pours a libation
at the small shrine in the courtyard on
behalf of his entire household
dexilea will remain at home all day
teaching her daughter's domestic skills
later she'll retire to the inner
courtyard for some fresh air
when archaeas arrives at the agora the
civic and commercial heart of the city
he finds the square swarming with his
fellow citizens
native-born adult males who have
completed military training
attached to the central monument is a
notice board with the meeting's agenda
today there's only one item of
discussion what to do with the people of
midlaney
a city on the island of lesbos where a
revolt against athenian rule
has just been put down the meeting takes
place on a hill
west of the acropolis known as the penix
the word means tightly packed and the
crowd of five thousand citizens
makes it clear why the heralds purify
the hill
by sprinkling its boundary with pig's
blood and call for order
as everyone sits on benches facing the
platform
the presiding officer opens the meeting
with the words
tis agoreven bulette who wishes to
address the assembly
one by one citizens speak some advising
mercy
others bent on vengeance a motion is
proposed to execute
all the mittalinans and enslave their
women and children
because they betrayed their athenian
allies during a time of war
a majority raises their right hands in
favor
once the meeting is over our chaos heads
back to the aggara to buy food and wine
hundreds have gathered there to discuss
the results many unhappy with the
decision
when arkias returns home he tells
dexilea about the debate
she thinks that killing the innocent as
well as the guilty is harsh and
counterproductive
and tells him as much around dusk
archies goes to a friend's house for a
symposium
the nine men drink wine and discuss the
meeting well into the night
archaea shares his wife's opinion urging
mercy and his friends eventually agree
before dawn something unprecedented
happens
heralds circulate throughout athens
announcing the council
has called another meeting the second
debate is equally heated
but a new resolution to execute only the
leaders of the revolt
narrowly passes yet there's a problem
a ship with orders to carry out the
first resolution was dispatched the
previous day
and so another ship quickly set sail to
countermand the order
a race of democracy against time
did you enjoy this glimpse of daily life
in an ancient civilization
if so check out our day in the life
playlist
you can also help us bring more
educational videos to lifelong learners
around the world by making a small
monthly contribution on our patreon page
at ted patreon.com
[Music]